my name is ray couture i'm
a professional astrologer how i feel
about astrology
most of the men in the comments be like
hey man we understand most of the ladies
be like
abba's being such a hater it's because
you don't because you don't know what it
is you don't know how it is it's like
yeah whatever
all right watch this is a professional
supposedly let's see how we do this
and how long have you been an astrologer
between 45 and 50 years
have you ever done anything like this
i'm not in a group setting but wherever
i am i look at somebody and say
are you a pisces and sometimes they say
yeah and sometimes
they say none of your business
i will say this guy is charming at the
very least which is
yeah absolutely perfect when you're
snake oil salesman you know what i mean
like
you have to use your personality to lure
these people in to want to believe
no you don't understand abba it really
works
you have to do it properly yeah sure
pyramid schemes as well
go on what do you mean you don't want to
make hundreds of thousands of dollars
i'm hearing your facebook you're not
trying to get [ __ ] filthy rich what's
wrong with you
now let me drive away in my mercedes
benz
what's your name nathaniel how tall are
you damn why does this guy look like
he's got done
butchering oh white supremacist this man
is crazy he's got his knife
on his back area he looks yeah when he's
not killing white supremacists he's
probably doing bike deliveries for uber
eats with his
rabbi hair nathaniel how tall are you
okay what makes me a scorpio to you
the intensity
bro i don't know if i can make it
through this episode
i had a big ass meal earlier and i'm
already backed up on all the poop
i can handle this [ __ ] is gonna
make me [ __ ] my pants
when you were growing up uh what kind of
problems did you have with your parents
they could never decide if they wanted
to be together or not do you worry a lot
absolutely mainly about my son just for
yourself
what are you looking for oh the ears of
a capricorn are just
chiseled i'll go with virgo okay
changing that to libra
what accepted it too you see your hand
so you're independent thinker yeah i'm
married to a transgender so you're trans
and i
appreciate the courage and the work i
feel to
becoming who you really are yeah did he
look at this man's hands and say
you're an independent thinker yeah
that's kind of like
when guys look at a girl's tits and like
you're very intelligent
hey you know what listen next time i
look at a girl's poom poom i'll be like
man
you you cook well
hi what's your name amalia
you put your foot forward when you were
growing up well
what did you want to be like a leader or
like actress
or something like fun and entertainer
for sure do you like to control things
around you yes i like it my way
most leos are like that she plays with
the balls
for sure this girl will not neglect
your testies god bless her you ever had
to tell her go to don't forget my balls
that's exactly
you should start at the test
[Music]
here i am this is fun
i don't care if i get any of them right
do you know that women
or men or people with red hair have a
lot of neanderthal dna
i've heard that one yet
so if he's a professional how many of
these does he have to get right to have
some semblance of
of having knowledge in this field none
of this
means anything because it's going to be
an explanation for anything
that's what i say all right raise your
hand if he got you correct
go ahead and turn around i'm afraid but
you got four people right yeah
based on nothing that had to do
with alignment of stars and planets in
when you were born so yeah sure
and that's not too bad who is the most
obvious
i don't know none of them apparently
why do you have a problem with astrology
what's the problem with astrology
because it's look some people be like i
just use it for fun and all this other
stuff cool story
okay if that's you whatever what i think
is
interesting about astrology is it's
inherently prejudicial
yes prejudice is the idea that you are
judging someone or attributing them
certain behavioral patterns or
characteristics
based off little to no evidence an
unfavorable opinion or feeling formed
beforehand or without knowledge thought
or reason okay
and that's why it's prejudiced because
if you look at somebody and be like well
you know what you're a virgo so that
means you probably smell
people are like oh that's just funny
whatever it's just like an astrology
thing now you replace virgo with indian
would you say that's not prejudiced of
course
oh yeah leos can't keep a job because
they're so hot-headed
replace leo with black people would you
not say that's prejudiced
replace leo so based off of things i
can't control which is when i was born
and where i was born you're going to
tell
me aspects of myself like well i haven't
don't understand and this is what they
always do they always move the goal post
when you talk to people
you don't understand it's more
complicated you got to look at the
rising moon and the falling stars and
then all of a sudden the nebula come
together and then
you know you got to look at the way and
i'm just like you got
you got to look at the culture you have
to look at the yeah
the history you got same thing potatoes
scientists have tried to prove the
accuracy of this mumbo jumbo they've had
experts from all over the world try to
replicate results at any kind of
consistent rate even with a little bit
they can't do it they can't do it and
when they get called out on it they say
well listen
it's too complicated to explain so i
think that's just why i get annoyed by
it
because it's goofy [ __ ] and you just
hear so many ladies go
i can never get with a capricorn it's
just
it's just open prejudice that's all it
is and i'm like what i like
what i like is really the i don't really
have a religion
i don't really like you know i can't i
don't have a religion i'm
spiritual i can't really go by those
things really the religion and stuff
like that it's too strict
but then the their they're hardcore
believers in astrology and to me i'm
like
well that's your religion bubu that's
you treat it as a religion that's what
you do
every day that you wake up that's your
religion
you have a religion your religion is
astrology
that's it yeah that's that's it you let
it
dictate how you're gonna interact with
people
yeah booboo [ __ ] that's religion
hey let me say this man women wanna
believe in magic
men want to learn magic yeah
right but there's also another layer to
this other noise
i feel like there's a certain level of
arrogance to think
that because venus is an erect critical
grade that's why you need to eat quinoa
on tuesday
like the world and the universe revolves
around you
right and it's just like you're not that
important
wow you're just in that constellations
that are so far
and then they'll come with these stupid
lines well abbot you'll recognize that
the moon
affects the cycle just because the moon
has some measure effect on us which is
one within our vicinity
doesn't mean that constellations so far
away have the same effect and you know
what the craziness
about this whole astrology thing you
know like what's your sign
what's my son yeah who cares just tell
me your sign
real quick my ascendant is leo
you know the irony is that because of
the axis of the earth
okay all the signs that we have used for
so long
are not exactly in the places that
they're supposed to be
meaning everyone is one sign over
meaning if you are a taurus you're
actually an aries
because all the signs that we thought
because of the tilting of earth so
none of it is none of it and look it's
not my opinion you can look this up
but it's just an interesting thing where
no matter how much facts and evidence
you bring to the table they'll always be
like
but i love magic and i'm just saying
you're like
you can't argue with this it's the
romance behind it that's what you like
you like the romance
you like the romance of different things
you like the romance of being able to
tell the future
tell what someone who someone is like
oh i know the truth i hold the truth i
know how that person is
i've done my calculation and i have the
truth everybody
in the human kind humankind always
wanted to have that
the knowledge the ultimate knowledge the
the romance of knowing everything about
someone
without even speaking to that person oh
you're so
wow you're such a it's crazy the energy
that you have
you know so much that's what it is and
you have the guru like people you're
like this and you're like that
and this happened to you oh be careful
with the voice
what was cling and then you break it
like the oracle
in uh the matrix one that's what it is
people want that they want to be the neo
they want to be neo morpheus the oracle
naiobi
they want to be everything they want to
live in that matrix and be able to
predict it
mr anderson they want to predict that
that's what they want to do
that's just a romance around it being
able to predict
do you believe in magic i sure do
because if i believe in it i don't have
a purpose and if i believe in that magic
it gives me a purpose yeah that's what
it is it's a religion
yeah hey listen and some people would
say i just like to
have fun with it cool maybe that's you
but i'm assuring you that there's other
women out there who are crazy
about this stuff and who act irrational
there's people that start their whole
day wrong
like oh what's wrong with you ah
okay venus is in gatorade again and i'm
gonna have a bad day
shut up and have your day yeah just have
it
you know what's crazy it's like they've
done studies where they told people like
what's your sign
like capricorn and like and then they
read them the like
the the stars chart for a leo and the
person's like oh yeah that sounds like
me
and they came to realize that most
people were gonna accept any kind of
reading that they were gonna give
even if it didn't match their sign
whatsoever so all in all it's just mumbo
jumbo
and it's okay you know what i like
pokemon too
it's fine the only difference is i know
pokemon are fake
okay i don't run around throwing
pokeballs expecting charizard to come
out
so let's just admit it that we like some
mumbo jumbo and then we can all have a
wonderful day
but you know what i don't do i don't say
oh
i want to find a rock trainer to mate
with me when i'm on tinder
you feel what i'm saying oh my god i
cannot get with a jigglypuffs
sugary ass pokemon oh you're into water
pokemon uh do you know what that means
it's stupid so this is my thought
process on it i think it's it's lame
but hey maybe i'm wrong maybe i just
don't know enough ladies if i'm wrong
why don't you let us know and fellas
since you guys already know how i feel
and you feel the same why don't you let
us know
actually you know what let it leave a
story below of some of the craziest
things that you may have heard or seen
with ladies who believe in astrology and
ladies if you know guys who are crazy
into that
by all means let us know as well um
i i wanna i wanna read some stories okay
so give me something i wanna hear
let's get spicy okay let's get some
spice on it that's it that's it
but anyways that's it for today's video
hope you guys enjoyed and yeah
[Music]